[Musik]
weil einfach es ist gerade die ladberger
geschlagen weil wir ja jetzt auch kurz
kommen jetzt nicht irgendwie nach der
bayern oder machen oder holen ich höre
ich vielleicht noch erinnert sich in
heftigen gesagt habe dass jana also
meine freundin jade entfällt und länder
zurzeit dabei also ein feld wo man sich
einfach zu meistern was an ihnen dran
greifen da hatten wir jetzt mal die idee
über ob das hören wollt jetzt jeden tag
mehr blogs machen dass er eigentlich ein
ganz gutes thema als diana mir
vielleicht dem heutigen blog einfach
mein erstes tattoo wald sind übrigens
gerade wieder 27 grad in köln um
irgendwie 11 uhr oder so muss ich sagen
ich bin jetzt kein typischer deutscher
das ich mein geld immer kälter aufträge
und bei wärme war wärme aber deutsche
wärme ist einfach so ohne wind und so
eher dritten spiel reihe zeigt dass man
es halt einfach nicht aus hält weiß
nicht wie ich gerade noch leben aber ich
würde sagen ich denke dass wir noch hier
die reste gewonnen und dann macht es mir
wenn man alle nudeln in ihrem kopf und
aneinanderreihten
die meilen will stellt meine freunde vor
und warten dass larry und sammy beiden
sehr unterhaltsame freunde der gute
freunde von mir leider auf einer
einzigen freundin supermarkt jede
nachricht dass dieser typ ist gewiss ist
nur die zum frühstück aber dann 300
gesamte boden schaut mein liebling
youtube den block der gäste kennt wen
hat im ordner mit zimmer und bar
wir sind gerade circa 800.000 grad
divergente block besteht mit der
halbwegs haut wenig daraus euro schwere
deutschland seien beschissen ist krieg
aber wo ich egal sondern bieten über
klima und temperaturen räder
ich fahre über fink also vom ersten ist
die auswahl der eigentlich greifen krank
übergang war vom ersten bis sechsten
juni mit in und meist sogar alles schon
meinen blogs gesehen also ich und hier
freunde von mir fahren an die nordsee um
irgendwo eine verlassene insel und
werden dort im urlaub machen den
entspannen und dort bin jeden tag ein
blogger und ihr in einem gemieteten haus
irgendwelche scheiße war fand ich bin
gerade aus meinem auch damit immer in
mein wohnzimmer gelaufen und jetzt laufe
ich wieder zurück warum ich das getan
hat weiß ich nicht
hallo jona
und als sektion auch schon wieder ab
jonas boog vorbeigekommen um ihn schritt
zu sagen weil er die letzten tage bei
max getan hat und derzeit wieder nach
hause fährt ich habe gerade den block
hochgeladenen ihr gestern gesehen habt
und engel macht dieses ganze blocking
negativ sparten bekommt ihr euch auch
mega gut an aber ich sitze immer so
lange im schnitt ich weiß man kann sich
das nicht vorstellen die börse total
beschissen aus den studien der jetzige
plan ist dass ich mir eben noch kurze
schnitte brot schmieren und danach zu
max greger rädern trainieren gehen
werden hier wenig das internationale
zeichen dafür dass man sich noch nicht
sicher ist ob man sich noch mit sein
wird macht oder das neue video
fitnesstraining auf youtube nicht
glauben das wichtigste vorne
muskeltraining ist nicht schön
geschnitten keller brot ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht wie man mich auf die idee
gekommen sind bei 32 grad raus zu gehen
[Musik]
gerade einfach kurzen das macht das
ganze macht mich das irgendwie aber es
hat irgendwie über nacht aus jetzt
wollen wir ganz schnell raus geschnitten
aber der trainiert immer noch
den weg bringen fitnessstudio also wir
gehen ein andere von dem unternehmen bei
dem wir sind und die haben anscheinend
noch gesehen auch missionen erfolgreich
[Musik]
alles sagt dass mich war ständig im
foyer die frage was hier mit ihren
freundinnen und mit ihrer familie
gemacht wird ihre kollegen tut mir sehr
leid das sagen zu müssen aber erklärt er
dass sich gerade zum sport gegangen bin
mit markt und auch möglich sind wir halt
an seinem mobilen geschäft
vorbeigelaufen ja unter wahrheit von
familienmitglieder von dir und auch ein
paar freunde und die hängen halt an
einer schnur
[Musik]
ja ja ich weiß es hat mich auch
abgefragt deswegen habe ich gedacht okay
dass wir den populären hashtag
verbreiten sollten das heißt freunde ihr
solltet auf jeden fall jetzt alle
kommentare falls er mithelfen ehre ich
meine digitale familienmitglieder von
poly und auch freunde wirklich irgendwie
einem schaufelt einfach in die anlagen
werden also neue heft ex-kollege wichtig
ökologie und geräten riesigen gefallen
zur wohnung ohne hinderliche beamten was
natürlich coole für populäre verkauft
werden aber als ich wollte schon anhand
der ukulele gehalten werden noch nicht
einvernehmlichen verlieren weil es mit
bekannt hat man auch lauf kriegen
zum abendessen oder halte ich hier
richtig schön ist weitere fragen sollte
helfen könne ob beginnen es nur auf
gewagte heute dazu bekommen ja ich mache
mir etwas zu essen und dann geh ich zu
maxim kann dann machen die mir das datum
als ich fragte was ich mich gerade
gekocht habe ich habe absolut keine
ahnung dass irgendwie gemüse mit reis
und curry den e schmecken
[Musik]
das geht so eine schlechte leistung
ich habe aufgegessen sehr beschissen
geschmeckt dass man gerade schon
geschrieben das internet zum vierten
beiden reihen wehren alves und halb
nachbarn
ich weiß das deutsche wetter bitten
hätte für die festspiele und so aber das
ist einfach nur geil am sommer das
einfach mit kurzer hose und t shirt
macht warum laufen kann und das ist
gerade wirklich in die 12 uhr also ich
bin angekommen bei ihm beide ist hier
der als jana unter anderem bis maximal
zwei wochen vermutlich von den
verwerfungen leben für das dann
irgendwann tattoo stechen lässt dann
würde ich einfach den tattoo maker so um
kennt oder mit messer wie wird ein
gestrichener erfreulich dass letztlich
mit dem
am und t shirt heute trainiert auch
nicht was geschehen ist hat man braucht
vor allem wirklich nicht dass er so
unsicher stiften ist dass das auch vom
stifter irgendwie vibrierten dass die
farbe ist die java errichtete lager
lieferten chefs meine kamera akkus fast
alles bewegen
wie kommen wir am meer die lange wartet
diese 20 linien gezogen und jetzt möchte
ganzen abwaschen hin des wird film
unterwegs aus dass unsere kunden mit
einem echten patienten die
sprachbarriere missbraucht haben ganz
cool ist meine erfahrung werde mich aber
auf dem arm stehen deswegen leute
schreibt allemal lupe und in die
kommentare wenn ihr kleid findet und
wenn nicht dann mag sich dekorieren noch
in den aufnahmen ein bisschen halt
einfach ein paar wochen hier dass hier
irgendwelche aufnahmen hinter seinen
video getreten deswegen kommt dann eben
jetzt erst mal schön ein richtig schöner
ich bin wieder da angekommen gewissen
standard aber auch schon hier vom
heutigen blog wie bereits gesagt würde
ich mir nie ein richtiges tattoo stechen
lassen weil ich einfach glaube ich nicht
damit klar kommen würde das ist mein
leben lang an dieser stelle dann
vorhanden
aber ich feiere tattoos und auch dieses
allerdings finde ich jetzt eine mega
coole erfahrung also wenn euch das noch
gefallen hat mich nicht mehr wehren uns
fragen wie wir und geborgen video
[Musik]